musique est plus que ce serait pour
quelles raisons non pas par nécessité de
manger voilà je pense à un crs qui
s'énerve actuellement dans les manifs et
s'ils pouvaient faire de double je crois
qu'il le ferait ouais
ah oui je pense et ce quasi fasoli nés
en 68 il a dû livrer prolétaires ce sont
les crs sans aller jusqu'à cet
engagement politique je pense
sincèrement séméac à 6 pour éviter de le
faire ils le feraient quoi simplement on
les manipule alors leur fout sur la
gueule et les étudiants les flics ses
trousses assez consternant comme
spectacle un jeune un flic qui se bat
avec un un jeune en banlieue c'est un
pauvre qu'il veut avec un pur et ça fait
juste quelqu'un qui manipule tout ce
team sur sa totalement désolant quoi
parce que la personne qui voit sa
voiture brûlée à mettre dans la merde
par contre la personne qui ça profite
fera monter les cotisations d'assurance
et sa voiture sera jamais brûlé
puisqu'il évite pas les mêmes quartiers
donc je trouve ça un peu désire vraiment
anti sociale serait ce que j'ai de la
compassion j'ai de la compassion pour
ces gens et je comprends les deux camps
je suis navré de voir le spectacle
société actuellement de séjour de droite
et de gauche qui se font sur la grotte
ça me désole quand il ya une chose à
[ __ ] dans ce pays qu'elles sont dues
les a priori sont toutes les compétences
requises ce cas pas le cas de laurent
nîmois d'ailleurs un il pourrait faire
les choses bien et on les voit sont
violées dans des débats puérils et ça je
trouve ça désolant franchement il ya
beaucoup de gens dans ce pays qui n'ont
qu'une envie en fait c'est que trouver
des solutions parce qu'il a des
problèmes mais là j'y vais militer la
classe politique est absolument navrant
j'ai parce que le sentiment que la masse
ce qu'on appelle la masse silencieuse de
masse populaire a plus de maturité
les gens qui nous dirigent j'en suis sûr
c'est vrai dire moi je vois tu pas
j'assume complètement
ils sont très disciplinés pouvait dire
non mais j'en veux pour m'insulter des
droits non mais ce que je veux dire
c'est que c'est si je votais je voterai
blanc les votes blanc n'étant pas validé
en france du coup je me retrouve un peu
embêté parce que je me reconnais aucun
discours mais ce que veut dire c'est que
si le vote blanc et elle était validée
on pourrait être façon pacifique
intelligent influencer sur démocratie
vraie je rejette ce candidat là je
rangeais il est pas normal qu en 2002 on
a le choix entre le pire et le moins
pire et jeudi c'est un grand pays ce
pays normalement c'est ce que j'entends
dire partout on a on a eu 30 % de votes
blancs et on aurait recommencé les
élections et c'est pas plus mal jusqu'à
ses dix candidats qui plaisent aux gens
le vote blanc avait de la valeur que si
le vote est obligatoire
il ya des tas de gens qui rêvent de
voter blanc de façon à changer la règle
du jeu
si le vote est obligatoire le vote blanc
serait considérée beaucoup
commençons par donner le vote blanc et
en ce cas l'état gens iront voter
aujourd'hui le vote blanc donne là une
voie à donner sa voix au plus fort
malheureusement celle-ci tu votes cinéma
mais je te dise il était valide
constitution loi n'existe pas le vôtre
actuellement six ont décidé que 15 ou 20
% de votes blancs étaient pouvait
invalider l'élection des tas de gens je
mettrai à voter de façon à changer
pacifiquement la règle et d'un jeu comme
personne ne comprend actuellement c'est
ce que je dis actuellement vaut
tellement effectivement revient pas
faire grand chose donc voila voila
c'était clairement au moins quand on
sait pas pour qui voter on peut savoir
si vous étiez fille qu'est ce que j'en
mettrais le plus bas depuis mai mais pas
des flics par contre les flics c'est un
boulot difficile et qui n'a pas
forcément la considération déjà autour
de soi quoi il n'y a pas de bons flics
et le mauvais flic c'est pas vrai y ait
des effets mais qui sont en mains mais
il ya des effets me tout d'un coup il ya
comme des mauvais supporters tu me
prends appareils sont gentils sont en
dessous de la gamme des gros cons quand
même un peu comme partout c'est pas si
vous étiez flics vous arrêteriez qui en
premier moi même voilà pour éviter de
faire des conneries et vous laisseriez
filet qui si vous étiez flic moi même
pas ma liberté
oui je travaillais sur qui si vous étiez
flic personnes les meubles feriez quoi
comme bavure des films comme réponse à
tout ce qui vous demande de faire
voter blanc vous j'en ai trop si c'est
bien parce que ça me ferait plaisir ça
sert vraiment là voilà je me semble plus
pareil je me sens fier les 6 12 ans
vient d'être français voilà si c'est
bien l'esprit critique
il faut faire c'est infiniment du fond
du coeur voilà jour y est surtout avec
quel accessoire le sifflet pour faire du
bruit
s'il est sceptique vous détesteriez plus
les noirs ou les arabes la connerie ces
métiers les flics vous seriez un peu
excité chaque fois vous passer des
menottes à quelqu'un si j'étais tout nu
peut-être je sais pas même essayé une
ethiopie que j'utiliserai quelle méthode
pour faire parler les gens ne votent
blanc vous étiez sais quel délit
laisseriez-vous impuni le les pétards
pas déconner quand même
le pétard lui les pétards fortis a du
nouveau maire d'estevelles vie paraît
que c'est très dangereux un coin un coup
sur deux il ya eu un rapport comme quoi
c'était une drogue douce ya deux ans
puis maintenant c'est très dangereux
plus de deux ans nous dira j moyens je
me faut arrêter c'est très simple filmez
jusqu'au prochain rapport à l'histoire
ailleurs que si vous étiez fait qu est
ce que vous seriez amoureux nicolas
sarkozy je démissionnerai
du monde à l'ordre
sans plus le magal